hi it's me ross matthews and i'm here
with kalpen hello hi so this is rapid
fire ross i'm going to hit you with some
real quick ones great i'll give you a
quick answer
[Music]
what is the most surprising part about
being engaged oh the most surprised
that's such a good question nobody's
actually ever asked me that probably
that i could have set up a registry oh
yeah for all the people who show you so
much love and congratulate you i was
like well if i hadn't known that i would
have set up like a nice big registration
and all the stuff we want the one thing
you do want and i love that it came to
you on a dream you were on a flight yeah
cardi b was on the flight yeah you fell
asleep and had a dream that she
appreciated your wedding correct you
tweeted it i tweeted it and i didn't
even tag her because i thought it might
be rude to tag her i didn't want to like
i have so much respect for her i didn't
want to do anything that would be
perceived as shade but she sees the
tweet somehow yeah and responds to it
and she says i'm down not only is she
down she's apparently officiated
weddings before and she's got the
whatever paperwork you need yeah and she
said she was super down so now it's on
us because we need to find a date so
when you're when you get on your phone
and cardi b is like tweeting you back
and saying officiate your wedding yeah
what do you do you look and you just say
yes yes i mean obviously i couldn't
believe it and then i like sent the
screenshot to like 20 of my friends like
yo you guys so is it happening i mean i
hope so we uh we we haven't really been
planning the wedding yet because of
covet and sure mostly because of covid
so we will see we want it to be safe for
our guests of course we have to talk
about what you did when you went and
worked at the white house yeah it blows
me away i'm fascinated by all things
politics cool yeah you have been there
in the white house yeah like what does
it smell like uh freedom smells like
freedom
what does freedom smell like like the
white house
and you worked there during the obama
years what is one thing that we don't
know about barack obama that's the thing
about people who have been in the public
eye or and or the leader of the free
world in that case obviously working on
things that are very important for a lot
of people and the stakes are really high
and it can be a high stress environment
but you really want to live up to the
expectations that your boss has and it's
very helpful when they're all so funny
you know it takes a little bit of the
sting out of a out of a rough day i also
i think you were looking for a little
more of a tidbit and a less political
answer so i'll tell you the one thing
that people don't often know about the
white house is that if you're a junior
staffer the the only food option really
is uh these vending machines in the
basement that you got to bring exact
change that's an outrage the west wing
has lied to us you can't order chinese
food like cj craig you just can't do it
well i do not vote for that well nobody
voted for that we can do better america
[Music]
i romanticized the white house in
politics so what's your favorite
political movie ever favorite political
movie ever that's such a good question
my fellow americans you know what i love
what an american president michael
douglas and that benning oh come on i
am the president i should have played
that role you should have all right do
the remake you know what we should do
let's do a buddy political comedy about
us both running for president super down
that's great and then do we become
running mates at the end yeah mm-hmm
don't spoil it
all right no
shoot well you just cut that part out
great all right cut
[Music]
you